- Bun venit la Înțelegerea
Informației și Computației Cuantice.
Mă numesc John Watrous și sunt directorul tehnic
al IBM Quantum Education.
Scopul acestei serii este să îți ofere
o înțelegere solidă a informației și computației cuantice, ceea ce înseamnă că vom intra
în detaliile tehnice
ale informației cuantice și vom vedea cum funcționează cu adevărat
computația cuantică, ce poate face și ce nu poate face.
Dacă nu ai vizionat deja
videoclipul de prezentare al acestei serii, te încurajez să îl urmărești.
În acel videoclip, vei găsi informații despre ce fel de pregătire
prealabilă este recomandată pentru această serie, precum și o schiță a
subiectelor care vor fi abordate.
De asemenea, asigură-te că verifici
manualul Qiskit, care acoperă același
material ca această serie video în formă scrisă,
și include și
componente interactive și interfețe cu hardware și software concepute pentru a te ajuta să înțelegi mai bine
informația și computația cuantică. Vei găsi linkuri către videoclipul de prezentare și manualul Qiskit
în descriere.
Aceasta este lecția unu a
unității unu din serie.
Unitatea unu acoperă bazele
informației cuantice, iar în prima lecție a acestei unități, ne vom concentra pe cum
funcționează informația cuantică
pentru sisteme individuale, ceea ce înseamnă că avem
un singur sistem fizic sau un dispozitiv de un anumit tip care
stochează informații cuantice
și luăm în considerare cum funcționează
acel sistem sau dispozitiv în izolare.
În lecția care urmează acesteia, vom discuta cum
funcționează informația cuantică atunci când avem sisteme multiple, ceea ce ne va permite
să descriem concepte interesante
și importante, cum ar fi algoritmii cuantici care utilizează mai mulți qubiți
și protocoale cuantice
care implică mai mulți indivizi ce procesează informații cuantice și le transmit înainte și
înapoi unul altuia.
Dar înainte de a intra în acele discuții, are sens să începem cu
cadrul comparativ simplu al unui sistem individual în izolare,
parțial pentru că este bine să începem simplu, dar și pentru că, după cum vom vedea, descrierea modului în care
funcționează informația cuantică
pentru sisteme individuale în izolare conduce foarte natural și logic la descrierea modului în care
pentru sisteme multiple.
Iată o scurtă prezentare a lecției.
Vom începe prin a discuta
informația clasică.
Acum, scopul acestei lecții nu este să explice cum
funcționează informația clasică, ci să explice cum
funcționează informația cuantică,
dar pentru a explica cum
funcționează informația cuantică, este foarte util să începem
cu informația clasică și să o folosim ca un
punct de referință familiar
atunci când discutăm informația cuantică.
La nivel matematic, informația cuantică și cea clasică au de fapt descrieri destul de similare, cu câteva diferențe cheie, bineînțeles.
De fapt, informația cuantică
nu este cu adevărat separată de informația clasică.
Este o extensie a
informației clasice.
Realitatea este,
cel puțin din punctul meu de vedere, că nu poți cu adevărat
să înțelegi informația cuantică dacă nu înțelegi
informația clasică,
deci are sens să începem cu
informația clasică.
Mă aștept ca acest
conținut să fie familiar unor privitori, dar chiar dacă îl cunoști, nu recomand să îl sari.
Pe lângă evidențierea aspectelor informației clasice care sunt cele mai relevante pentru
înțelegerea informației cuantice, vom introduce notația
Dirac în această parte,
care este un mod standard
pe care îl vom folosi pentru a descrie vectori și
matrice pe parcursul seriei.
Se dovedește că notația Dirac nu este
specifică informației cuantice.
Poate fi folosită la fel de bine în contextul informației clasice, cât și în multe alte situații unde apar vectori și matrice.
Vom trece apoi la informația cuantică și, în mod specific, vom
discuta reprezentarea stărilor cuantice ca vectori,
un tip simplu de măsurare numit măsurare în baza standard și operații unitare, care descriu schimbările discrete în timp
ale sistemelor cuantice.
Din nou, toate în cadrul
sistemelor individuale.
Înainte să începem cu lecția propriu-zisă, va fi util să clarificăm că există de fapt două descrieri
ale informației cuantice: descrierea simplificată, care este ceea ce vom
examina în această lecție
și pe tot parcursul primei unități, și descrierea generală, care este acoperită într-o unitate ulterioară, mai specific în
unitatea a treia a seriei.
Descrierea simplificată,
conform numelui său, este mai simplă și
se învață de obicei prima.
În descrierea simplificată, după cum am sugerat deja, stările cuantice sunt reprezentate de vectori, iar operațiile sunt reprezentate
de matrice unitare.
Această descriere a informației
cuantice este suficientă pentru înțelegerea
majorității algoritmilor cuantici, de exemplu,
deci nu este prea simplificată, este lucrul real.
Totuși, pe măsură ce vom
descoperi în timp, are anumite limitări.
De exemplu, dacă vrem să
modelăm efectele zgomotului asupra sistemelor cuantice, această descriere se dovedește a fi insuficientă.
WEBVTT
Descrierea generală, pe de
altă parte, este mai generală și, în cele din urmă, este mai
puternică în sens matematic.
În această descriere, stările cuantice sunt reprezentate de o clasă specială de matrice
numite matrice de densitate,
și o clasă mai generală de
măsurări și operații poate fi descrisă, incluzând
zgomotul, de exemplu.
Este în întregime consistentă cu
descrierea simplificată și, de fapt, poți practic vedea
descrierea simplificată
ca un caz special al
descrierii generale, și include și informația clasică ca un caz special.
Este și cu adevărat
frumoasă în modul în care funcționează totul, deci te încurajez cu tărie să înveți despre această descriere generală
când vine momentul potrivit, dar descrierea simplificată este locul mai natural de a începe, și deci acesta este ceea ce vom face.
Vom începe prin a vorbi despre informația clasică cu un ochi pe aspectele
informației clasice care sunt cele mai relevante
pentru informația cuantică
și modul în care este
descrisă matematic.
Imaginează-ți că avem un
sistem fizic sau un dispozitiv de un anumit tip care stochează informații.
Vom numi acest sistem X, dar nu există nimic
important despre acest nume.
Am putea folosi orice alt
nume dacă am prefera, dar pentru a alege un nume,
îl vom numi sistemul X.
Vom face o ipoteză despre X, care este că există un
set finit de stări clasice în care X poate fi
la orice moment dat.
Aici, când mă refer la o stare clasică, mă refer la o configurație a sistemului care poate fi recunoscută și
descrisă fără ambiguitate
fără nicio incertitudine sau eroare.
De fapt, acesta este ceva la care poți gândi intuitiv. La nivel matematic, pur și simplu definim
setul de stări clasice,
îl alegem cum vrem sau în orice mod care descrie cel mai bine
dispozitivul cu care lucrăm.
Să dăm numele sigma acestui
set de stări clasice, și din nou, să subliniez
că presupunem că sigma este un set finit.
Setul de stări clasice
ale acestui sistem X nu este infinit de mare ca
setul tuturor numerelor naturale.
Este finit, și aceasta este doar
o ipoteză pe care o facem.
De exemplu, ar putea fi că X este un bit, caz în care setul de stări clasice este setul conținând două
elemente: zero și unu.
Uneori ne referim la acest
set ca alfabetul binar.
Un alt exemplu este că X este
un zar obișnuit cu șase fețe, caz în care stările clasice sunt numerele de la unu la șase.
Desigur, vorbim
despre o abstractizare aici.
Un zar real cu șase fețe poate
avea multe atribute diferite, cum ar fi poziția sa exactă, orientarea sa,
temperatura sa, și așa mai departe. Dar în ceea ce privește informația care este cel mai tipic relevantă când vorbim despre un zar cu șase fețe,
stările clasice sunt
numerele de la unu la șase, indicate de numărul de puncte pe oricare față a zarului este orientată în sus.
Dacă X este un comutator pe un
ventilator electric standard pe care l-ai putea avea acasă, atunci poate stările clasice
sunt setările mare,
mediu, mic și oprit.
Acestea sunt doar exemple. Ne-am putea imagina sisteme cu seturi de stări clasice
diferite, dar sper că transmit ideea
că această noțiune de stare clasică este ceva care ar trebui să fie
familiar și poate fi înțeleasă în termeni simpli și intuitivi.
Matematic vorbind, setul de stări clasice
este doar un set finit, și, desigur, acest set trebuie
să fie și non-gol.
Trebuie să existe cel puțin
o stare clasică în care sistemul poate fi și trebuie să existe cel puțin două stări clasice
dacă sistemul va fi util pentru stocarea informațiilor.
Acum, în unele situații, am putea ști că X este
într-o anumită stare, dar în multe situații,
care apar în cadrul
procesării informațiilor, poate exista incertitudine despre starea clasică a unui
sistem la un moment particular
astfel încât fiecare posibilă stare clasică are o anumită probabilitate asociată cu ea.
De exemplu, dacă X este un bit, atunci poate este cazul că X se află în starea clasică zero
cu probabilitatea trei sferturi și se află în starea unu
cu probabilitatea un sfert.
Ne vom referi la aceasta
ca o stare probabilistică, și am putea exprima
această stare probabilistică, după cum vezi chiar aici,
pur și simplu indicând care sunt
probabilitățile pentru diferitele stări clasice.
Un mod mai concis de a exprima
această stare probabilistică este printr-un vector, mai specific reprezentarea
pe care o vezi chiar aici
este un vector coloană, și acest vector indică
care sunt probabilitățile pentru cele două posibile stări clasice.
Mai specific, prima intrare indică
care este probabilitatea ca X să fie în starea zero, iar a doua intrare ne spune care este probabilitatea
ca sistemul să fie în starea unu. Aceasta este pur și simplu modalitatea naturală de a ordona alfabetul binar,
sau cel puțin, este modul în care
suntem instruiți să facem asta. Cu zero primul și unu al doilea.
De acum înainte, vom folosi
termenul vector de probabilitate pentru a indica un vector ca acesta.
WEBVTT
Mai specific, este un vector ale cărui intrări sunt toate
numere reale non-negative și unde suma
intrărilor este egală cu unu,
deci are sens să
gândim despre aceste intrări ca probabilități.
Aici, în acest exemplu, există doar două intrări pentru că există doar două
stări clasice ale sistemului despre care vorbim,
dar în general, ar putea exista
orice număr de intrări, cu înțelegerea
că există câte o intrare pentru fiecare stare clasică
al oricărui sistem despre care vorbim.
Vom continua să
discutăm informația clasică, vectorii de probabilitate și
altele de acest fel imediat, dar mai întâi, va fi cu adevărat util
să introducem o notație
pentru a descrie vectori, cunoscută sub numele de notația Dirac.
De fapt, aceasta este doar prima
parte a notației Dirac.
Există câteva alte
aspecte ale notației Dirac pe care le vom vedea puțin
mai târziu în lecție.
Această notație va fi
destul de centrală pentru modul în care descriem informația cuantică, deci este esențial să
înțelegi cum funcționează,
dar din fericire, este foarte simplă și nu are cu adevărat
nicio legătură specifică cu informația cuantică,
deci o putem introduce acum
în contextul familiar al informației clasice.
Ca înainte, presupunem că avem un set sigma de
stări clasice ale unui sistem, și să presupunem
că avem o ordonare
a acestor stări clasice, la fel cum ne referim la o
ordonare a alfabetului binar
în exemplul precedent. Un alt mod de a spune aceasta
este că elementele lui sigma sunt puse în corespondență
cu numerele întregi
de la unu la oricât de multe
elemente conține sigma, ceea ce este ce înseamnă această notație de aici cu două bare în jurul lui sigma.
Acesta este numărul de
elemente din setul sigma.
Deci există o primă stare,
o a doua stare, și așa mai departe.
Ordonarea specifică sau
corespondența pe care o alegem nu va conta de fapt foarte mult.
Ceea ce este cu adevărat important este
că avem o ordonare și ne ținem de ea.
Pentru multe seturi de stări clasice
pe care le vom întâlni, va exista o ordonare standard la fel cum avem cu
alfabetul binar,
și dacă nu există o ordonare standard, putem doar să alegem una.
Dar oricare ar fi, înțelegerea este că ne ținem de ea.
Iată acum notația
care este introdusă.
Pentru orice alegere a unei stări
clasice a din setul nostru sigma, scriem aceasta chiar aici, care se citește ca ket a
și înseamnă vectorul coloană
care are un unu în intrarea corespunzătoare lui a și un zero pentru toate celelalte intrări.
De exemplu, dacă revenim
la alfabetul binar, care, după cum ai putut ghici, este un exemplu foarte important
la care ne vom întoarce din nou și din nou. Atunci ket zero și ket unu sunt vectorii definiți chiar aici.
Ket zero este vectorul
care are un unu în intrarea corespunzătoare stării clasice zero, care este prima intrare,
și un zero pentru toate celelalte intrări, și în acest caz, există
doar o altă intrare.
Similar, ket unu este
acest vector chiar aici unde avem un unu în
intrarea corespunzătoare lui unu,
care este a doua intrare, și un zero pentru toate celelalte intrări, care, din nou, este doar o intrare.
Iată un alt exemplu. În acest exemplu, avem un set de stări clasice sigma corespunzând celor patru culori
dintr-un pachet standard de cărți de joc: treflă, caro, inimă și pică.
În acest caz, nu există cu adevărat o
ordonare universal acceptată a acestor culori.
Pentru multe jocuri de cărți, nu există nicio ordonare. Sunt pur și simplu patru culori diferite și asta e tot ce contează, și există diferite jocuri de cărți care ordonează aceste culori
în moduri diferite, dar nu contează cu adevărat.
Putem alege pur și simplu o
ordonare ca cea pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Aceasta se întâmplă să fie ordonarea alfabetică conform numelor acestor patru culori scrise în engleză,
presupunând că am ales
această ordonare particulară, atunci definim acești patru vectori: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts și ket spades
după cum se vede chiar aici, și acești vectori corespund
descrierii generale pe care o vezi sus.
Dat fiind că am ales
această ordonare particulară pentru aceste patru culori.
Putem face același lucru pentru orice set de stări clasice
pe care îl alegem.
Ținând minte că setul de stări clasice înseamnă întotdeauna set finit și non-gol.
Vectorii de această formă se
numesc vectori de bază standard, și este un fapt foarte fundamental despre vectori că orice vector poate fi
exprimat în mod unic
ca o combinație liniară
de vectori de bază standard.
De exemplu, revenind la exemplul de acum doar un moment, vectorul de probabilitate
pe care l-am văzut poate fi exprimat
după cum se vede chiar aici. Este practic doar o modalitate alternativă de a exprima vectorii
care va fi foarte la îndemână din mai multe motive în continuare.
WEBVTT
Și cu acea notație acum în mâinile noastre, să revenim la discuția
despre informația clasică și stările probabilistice, în particular.
Și să considerăm ce se întâmplă
când măsurăm un sistem în timp ce se află într-o stare probabilistică.
Nu am face de obicei
referire la o măsurare sau la actul de a măsura
ceva într-un cadru clasic, dar termenul are sens.
În esență, când vorbim
despre măsurarea sistemului X în acest context, înseamnă pur și simplu că îl privim și recunoaștem în ce stare se află.
Desigur, când ne uităm la sistem, nu vedem o stare probabilistică, vedem o stare clasică,
și starea clasică particulară
pe care o vedem este una pe care ne-o putem imagina
că este aleasă aleatoriu conform probabilităților.
Acum, ai putea obiecta din
motive filosofice la ideea că starea clasică pe care o vedem este cumva aleasă aleatoriu
în momentul în care măsurăm sau ne uităm la sistem; sistemul pur și simplu era într-o anumită
stare clasică tot timpul
și tocmai am aflat
care era starea, dar în scopul de a gândi despre cadrul matematic
cu care lucrăm,
este în regulă să gândim astfel, iar făcând asta ne va permite să tragem o paralelă cu
informația cuantică puțin mai târziu.
Să presupunem că
starea clasică pe care o vedem este starea clasică a, care ar putea fi orice stare din setul nostru sigma.
Aceasta schimbă starea probabilistică
a lui X în general, cel puțin din punctul nostru de vedere.
Probabilitățile nu mai
au nicio semnificație pentru că știm acum care
este starea clasică a lui X.
Este a, și nu mai există
nicio incertitudine despre asta.
Deci am spune acum
că probabilitatea ca sistemul să fie în starea a este unu.
Știm asta pentru că tocmai ne-am uitat la el și am văzut că starea clasică este a, deci noua stare probabilistică a lui X este una
în care probabilitatea de
a fi în starea clasică a este egală cu unu.
Și acea stare probabilistică este reprezentată de
vectorul de probabilitate ket a.
Avem un unu în intrarea corespunzătoare stării clasice a și un zero în toate celelalte intrări.
De exemplu, dacă considerăm din nou
situația în care X este un bit și avem aceeași
stare probabilistică ca înainte,
atunci dacă măsurăm X, ne putem imagina că
are loc o tranziție.
Cu probabilitatea trei sferturi, vedem starea clasică zero, și prin măsurare, trecem la ket zero
ca stare probabilistică,
și cu probabilitatea un sfert, trecem la ket unu.
Poți gândi la aceasta ca o tranziție a cunoașterii, dacă preferi, spre deosebire de o tranziție
fizică reală,
dar ceea ce este important pentru
scopul acestei lecții este să recunoaștem cum funcționează matematica.
Este oarecum trivial de fapt, dar recunoscând această trivialitate, descrierea analogă
pentru cadrul cuantic
ar putea părea puțin mai puțin misterioasă.
O notă finală este că pentru o altă persoană care nu a văzut
care era starea clasică a lui X când l-am măsurat,
starea probabilistică
în mod natural nu s-ar schimba ca urmare a faptului că l-am măsurat.
Asta e în regulă. Diferiți indivizi pot
avea cunoștințe diferite despre un anumit sistem și în consecință pot alege
stări probabilistice diferite
pentru a reprezenta
cunoștințele lor despre acel sistem.
În ultima parte a acestei discuții despre informația clasică, vom vorbi despre operațiile clasice care pot fi efectuate pe un sistem,
începând cu operațiile deterministe.
Când efectuăm o operație pe un sistem, starea sa se schimbă de obicei ca rezultat, și în acest context, cuvântul determinist înseamnă
că rezultatul efectuării
operației depinde în întregime de orice
stare clasică în care se afla sistemul
înainte de efectuarea operației.
Cu alte cuvinte, nu există
un element de șansă atunci când o operație deterministă
este efectuată, deci nu există aleatorie
sau incertitudine implicată.
În termeni matematici, operațiile deterministe
sunt descrise de funcții.
Fiecare funcție f de forma
pe care o vezi chiar aici, ceea ce înseamnă că atât intrarea cât și ieșirea funcției
corespund elementelor
setului nostru de stări clasice sigma, descrie o operație deterministă.
Starea clasică a este
transformată în starea f de a, pentru fiecare alegere a stării a.
Pentru fiecare funcție f de această formă, va exista întotdeauna o matrice unică M satisfăcând această condiție
pe care o vezi chiar aici,
și aceea este că înmulțind
M cu vectorul ket a ne dă vectorul ket f de a,
și aceasta este adevărat pentru fiecare
alegere a stării clasice a.
Nu este prea dificil să scriem
o descriere explicită a lui M dat orice funcție f
de această formă pe care am ales-o.
Va avea întotdeauna exact
un unu în fiecare coloană, cu toate celelalte intrări egale cu zero.
Și iată formula. Intrarea b, a a lui M este egală cu unu dacă b este egal cu f de a
și altfel, este egală cu zero, și prin aceasta, înțelegem
că aceasta este intrarea lui M al cărei rând corespunde lui b
și a cărei coloană corespunde lui a.
WEBVTT
Vom vedea câteva exemple imediat și vom vedea de ce funcționează această formulă.
Acum, s-ar putea să nu fie clar de ce am vrea să luăm o funcție și să o exprimăm ca o matrice ca aceasta,
dar are sens să facem asta. Unul dintre motive, și poate că este motivul principal, este că dacă avem un sistem
într-o stare probabilistică
și efectuăm o operație deterministă
pe acel sistem, atunci starea probabilistică rezultată
poate fi obținută
prin înmulțirea matrice-vector, adică dacă sistemul nostru se află
într-o stare probabilistică
reprezentată de
un vector de probabilitate v și efectuăm operația deterministă descrisă de M
pe acel sistem, atunci starea probabilistică rezultantă va fi dată de M înmulțit cu v.
Aici, apropo, această săgeată cu o
bară mică pe ea ca aceasta este doar o notație comună în matematică pentru a indica cum un lucru este mapat la
sau transformat în altceva. Poți folosi doar o săgeată obișnuită, dar aceasta este convențională
și este recognoscibilă și poate este puțin mai specifică decât doar o săgeată, care ar putea însemna multe lucruri diferite.
Acum să aruncăm o privire la un exemplu sau mai degrabă o colecție de exemple.
Să considerăm ce se întâmplă când luăm setul nostru de stări clasice sigma ca din nou alfabetul binar.
Nu există prea multe funcții diferite de forma despre care am discutat când acesta este setul nostru de stări clasice și, mai precis, există exact patru
funcții de această formă.
Iată, acele patru funcții sunt descrise prin tabelele lor de valori.
Primul tabel descrie
prima funcție, pe care am numit-o f1.
Pentru fiecare posibilă intrare pe stânga, listăm ieșirea corespunzătoare
pe dreapta, deci f1 de zero este egal cu zero,
și f1 de unu este, din nou, egal cu zero, ceea ce înseamnă că f1 este
funcția constantă zero.
Are întotdeauna valoarea zero.
A doua funcție f2
este funcția identitate.
Ieșirea este întotdeauna egală cu intrarea, după cum poți vedea din al doilea tabel.
A treia funcție f3 este
descrisă de al treilea tabel.
f3 de zero este egal cu unu, și f3 de unu este egal cu zero.
Această funcție este mai bine
cunoscută ca funcția not sau negarea logică.
Uneori o numim și bit flip pentru că inversează zero
la unu și unu la zero.
Ultima funcție f4 este,
din nou, o funcție constantă la fel ca prima, dar aceasta este funcția constantă unu
pentru că are întotdeauna valoarea unu.
Și acelea sunt singurele patru funcții de la alfabetul binar la el însuși.
Iată cele patru matrice care corespund acestor patru funcții, descrise de
formula de mai devreme,
pe care o poți vedea chiar aici, și dacă vrei, poți opri videoclipul și verifica aceasta.
Ține minte că pentru matrice, ordinea indicilor este întotdeauna mai întâi rândurile, apoi coloana.
Deci intrarea b, a corespunde
rândului b și coloanei a sau rândul care corespunde
stării clasice b
și coloana care corespunde
stării clasice a.
De exemplu, dacă privim
prima funcție, avem că f1 de zero este egal cu zero
și corespunzător, intrarea
zero, zero a lui M1 este egală cu unu.
Ei bine, intrarea unu, zero
care este chiar aici este egală cu zero, și poți face același lucru pentru cazul
în care intrarea este egală cu unu și similar pentru celelalte
trei funcții.
Poți de asemenea verifica că
formula de mai devreme este adevărată și poți parcurge una câte una toate posibilitățile diferite pentru a verifica asta.
Și de fapt, dacă te gândești la modul în care
înmulțirea matricelor funcționează, poți cam vedea asta cu ochiul liber.
Când înmulțești o matrice cu un vector de bază standard ca acesta, poți imagina că
iei intrarea
și o introduci în
vârful uneia dintre matrice, în coloana care corespunde
stării clasice
din interiorul ket-ului, și ieșirea pe care
o obții este pur și simplu acea coloană ca vector de probabilitate.
De exemplu, M3 înmulțit cu ket
zero îți dă zero, unu
ca vector de probabilitate, care este ket unu.
M3 înmulțit cu ket
unu îți dă unu, zero, care este ket zero și așa mai departe.
Vom discuta mai mult operațiile pe
stări probabilistice imediat, dar mai întâi, să introducem a doua parte a notației Dirac.
Aceasta va fi utilă
pentru a vorbi despre operații și a gândi despre ele ca matrice, și va fi de asemenea un instrument standard
pe care îl vom folosi în continuare. Configurarea este la fel ca înainte.
Avem orice set de stări clasice sigma cu care lucrăm și presupunem că avem un mod de
a ordona acele stări clasice.
Atunci scriem acest lucru
pe care îl vezi chiar aici unde de data aceasta bara
unghiulară este pe stânga în loc de dreapta, pentru a înseamnă
vectorul rând cu un unu
în intrarea care
corespunde lui a și un zero pentru toate celelalte intrări corespunzând tuturor
celorlalte stări clasice.
Deci diferența dintre
acesta și ket a este că acesta este un vector rând și
ket a este un vector coloană,
WEBVTT
dar altfel, vectorii
sunt definiți în mod similar.
Citim acesta ca bra a; nu știu dacă se vrea a fi amuzant, dar ideea este că numele bra și ket
sunt cele două jumătăți ale cuvântului bracket, și vom mai spune
câte ceva despre asta imediat.
Dar mai întâi, să aruncăm o privire
la un exemplu foarte rapid.
Pentru alfabetul binar, avem că bra zero este
acest vector rând chiar aici, analog cu ket a,
cu excepția că este un vector rând
în loc de un vector coloană, și bra unu este acest vector chiar aici.
Acum, în general, dacă înmulțim un vector
rând cu un vector coloană, gândindu-ne la aceștia ca matrice
care au doar
un rând sau o singură coloană, obținem o matrice unu la unu, pe care o putem gândi
ca un scalar.
Apropo, ar trebui să
gândești la aceste steluțe ca reprezentând numere arbitrare.
În particular, dacă
înmulțim vectorul rând bra a cu vectorul coloană ket b,
atunci există două lucruri care se pot întâmpla.
Unul este că a și b sunt egale, deci sunt aceeași stare clasică, caz în care unitățile se vor alinia
și produsul va fi egal cu unu sau ar putea fi cazul
că a și b sunt diferite,
și deci unitățile nu se aliniază și produsul este egal cu zero.
Un mod simplu de a exprima
aceste observații este acesta chiar aici.
Și pentru a păstra lucrurile ordonate, scriem acest produs astfel, cu o singură bară la mijloc, și înseamnă exact același
lucru ca acesta chiar aici.
Și acum poți vedea cum
bra și ket se combină pentru a forma un bracket, care se mai numește și produs intern,
și acesta este ceva
destul de important la care vom reveni
în lecția numărul trei.
Înmulțind un vector
coloană cu un vector rând, pe de altă parte, ne dă o matrice, după cum poți vedea chiar aici.
Deci de exemplu, revenind din nou
la alfabetul binar, dacă înmulțim ket zero cu bra zero,
obținem această matrice chiar aici, și putem parcurge
celelalte posibilități pentru a vedea ce se întâmplă.
Ket zero înmulțit cu bra unu ne dă
această matrice chiar aici, unde unitatea s-a mutat
acum în această poziție.
Ket unu, bra zero arată astfel și iată ket unu, bra unu.
Ceea ce vedem că se întâmplă este că există un singur unu într-o matrice altfel plină de zerouri, și poziția acelui unu
este determinată de
stările clasice pe care le alegem în bra și ket.
Mai precis, și
aceasta este adevărat în general, pentru orice alegere a unui set de stări clasice, matricea pe care o obținem înmulțind ket a cu bra b
este matricea cu un unu în intrarea a, b și un zero pentru toate celelalte intrări.
Și acum că avem atât
prima cât și a doua parte a notației Dirac, avem un instrument foarte la îndemână pentru a conecta operațiile cu matricele.
Deci să revenim pe scurt
la operațiile deterministe și să ne amintim că puțin
mai devreme în lecție,
s-a afirmat că pentru fiecare funcție f de
această formă chiar aici, avem o operație deterministă care transformă a în f de a
pentru fiecare posibilă stare clasică a. Și am spus că pentru
orice funcție ca aceasta, există întotdeauna o matrice unică
M care acționează astfel
pe stările bazei standard.
Folosind notația Dirac, putem acum exprima foarte ușor această matrice după cum se vede chiar aici,
și putem vedea cum uneori
este posibil să lucrăm cu matrice în întregime
în cadrul notației Dirac
fără a converti niciodată explicit
la vectori și matrice, adică dreptunghiuri umplute cu numere.
În acest caz, putem verifica că
formula necesară este adevărată înmulțind M cu ket a.
Substituim
expresia noastră pentru M astfel și putem elimina parantezele și lipi bra
b cu ket a astfel.
Și aceasta deoarece
înmulțirea matricelor este liniară, în acest caz în primul argument și este asociativă, deci putem elimina parantezele.
Și acum, amintindu-ne că avem un a fix despre care vorbim pe măsură ce sumăm toate
posibilele alegeri ale lui b,
acest bracket chiar aici va
fi întotdeauna egal cu zero când b nu este egal cu a, deci nu va exista nicio
contribuție la sumă,
și când b este egal cu a, bracket-ul va fi egal cu unu și deci vom rămâne cu
acest singur termen chiar aici.
Aceasta este formula pe care o doream și deci avem o modalitate foarte frumoasă și simplă de a exprima o funcție ca o matrice.
Pe lângă operațiile deterministe, avem și operații care
introduc prin ele însele aleatorie sau incertitudine despre
starea clasică a unui sistem.
Folosim termenul operație probabilistică pentru a înseamnă operații ca aceasta, și mai precis, când spunem operație probabilistică,
înțelegem operații care
ar putea introduce aleatorie, deci operațiile deterministe sunt de fapt un caz special
al operațiilor probabilistice
care pur și simplu nu întâmplă
să introducă aleatorie.
Iată un exemplu simplu unde
este introdusă ceva aleatorie.
Aceasta este o operație pe un singur bit. Modul în care funcționează este că dacă starea clasică
a bitului este zero,
atunci nu se întâmplă nimic. Bitul rămâne zero, dar dacă starea clasică
a bitului este unu, atunci operația întoarce bitul la zero
WEBVTT
cu probabilitatea egală cu 1/2.
Nu există un nume special
pentru această operație, cel puțin nu știu de vreunul.
Este doar un exemplu, dar ți-ai putea imagina
efectuând această operație pe un bit.
La fel ca operațiile deterministe, operațiile probabilistice pot
fi reprezentate de matrice, iar acțiunile lor pe stările probabilistice
sunt date de înmulțirea matrice-vector, la fel ca înainte.
De data aceasta, nu este neapărat cazul că matricele au exact un unu în fiecare coloană și zerouri altfel.
Operațiile probabilistice sunt
mai general reprezentate de matrice stocastice.
Acestea sunt matrice ale căror intrări sunt toate
numere reale non-negative și unde intrările din
fiecare coloană sumează la unu.
Aceasta este echivalent cu a spune
că matricele stocastice sunt matrice unde fiecare coloană
formează un vector de probabilitate.
Are sens când te gândești la
acțiunea unei matrice pe un vector de bază standard.
Iei orice
stare clasică dorești și îți imaginezi că introduci acea stare în vârful matricei, în coloana care corespunde
acelei stări clasice,
și acea coloană îți spune care
este starea probabilistică care iese ca vector de probabilitate.
Operația probabilistică
din exemplul nostru, de exemplu, este descrisă de această matrice chiar aici.
Dacă efectuăm această operație
pe starea clasică zero, atunci starea probabilistică pe care o obținem este dată de prima coloană,
care este, din nou, starea clasică zero sau echivalent, starea probabilistică
în care zero apare cu probabilitatea unu.
Dacă în schimb efectuăm această operație pe starea clasică unu, atunci în mod efectiv randomizăm bitul și corespunzător obținem
acest vector de probabilitate chiar aici
unde probabilitatea pentru
fiecare dintre posibilele stări este egală cu 1/2.
În general, dacă efectuăm această operație pe orice stare probabilistică, atunci efectul este practic
doar o medie ponderată între cele două coloane
deoarece astfel funcționează
înmulțirea matrice-vector.
Este liniară, deci facem media celor două
posibile rezultate în consecință.
Când ne gândim la operațiile probabilistice
în acest mod, este natural să ne gândim la
ele ca potențial introducând sau injectând aleatorie.
Putem citi coloanele una câte una și putem vedea aleatorismul
pe care îl introduc pentru fiecare posibilă stare clasică.
Poți de asemenea gândi despre
operațiile probabilistice într-un mod ușor diferit, și anume că sunt alegeri aleatorii de operații deterministe.
De exemplu, în exemplul nostru, putem gândi la această operație ca echivalentă cu
aruncarea unei monede corecte
și fie efectuând
funcția constantă zero, fie funcția identitate,
fiecare cu probabilitatea 1/2,
și poți vedea aceasta reflectată
chiar aici prin această ecuație.
Aceasta este întotdeauna posibilă pentru
orice operație probabilistică, și este destul de intuitiv.
Dacă ai face alegeri aleatorii
ca parte a unui proces, ți-ai putea imagina întotdeauna că faci acele alegeri aleatorii în avans
și apoi le codifici rigid
în niște colecție de operații deterministe.
Este uneori destul de util să gândești la operațiile probabilistice
în acest mod, și vom vedea un exemplu
al acestui lucru mai departe în câteva lecții.
Ultimul lucru de spus
despre informația clasică pentru această lecție se referă la compunerea
operațiilor probabilistice, ceea ce înseamnă pur și simplu efectuarea
uneia după alta.
Să presupunem că
avem un sistem numit X și M1 până la Mn sunt matrice stocastice reprezentând operații probabilistice
pe X.
Imaginează-ți mai întâi că avem
un vector de probabilitate v, care reprezintă o stare probabilistică
a lui X la un moment dat, și apoi aplicăm mai întâi
prima operație probabilistică pe X, care este reprezentată de matricea M1, și apoi aplicăm a doua operație probabilistică,
care este reprezentată de M2.
Dacă facem asta, atunci
vectorul de probabilitate pe care îl obținem după aplicarea doar a primei
operații este M1 ori v,
și apoi când aplicăm
a doua operație, vectorul de probabilitate rezultant este M2 înmulțit cu orice vector am obținut
după aplicarea lui M1. Deci arată astfel.
Acum, înmulțirea matricelor
este o operație asociativă, ceea ce înseamnă că nu contează unde punem aceste paranteze.
Deci am putea la fel de ușor
pune parantezele astfel.
Este foarte simplu, dar este și interesant pentru că dezvăluie că
putem gândi la operația în care mai întâi aplicăm M1
și apoi aplicăm M2
ca o singură operație.
Cu alte cuvinte, operația
probabilistică pe care o obținem compunând prima și
a doua operație probabilistică este reprezentată de
produsul matrice, M2 ori M1,
și aceea este aceeași operație indiferent de ce stare probabilistică
am început.
Nu trebuie să știm nimic despre vectorul de probabilitate v pentru a gândi despre sau descrie
această operație compusă.
Observă că ordinea
de aici este M2 pe stânga și M1 pe dreapta, ceea ce este pentru că
matricea din dreapta, M1,
este cea care se
înmulțește cu vectorul v, în timp ce M2 se înmulțește
cu orice vector obținem după înmulțirea cu M1.
WEBVTT
Deci trebuie să avem mereu în minte că ordinea în anumite
privințe este inversată.
Operația efectuată
prima este cea din dreapta, iar operația efectuată ultima sau în acest caz a doua,
este cea din stânga.
Dacă nu ne oprim la a doua operație și le aplicăm pe toate
în ordine, începând cu prima și terminând cu ultima, care este Mn,
atunci compoziția tuturor
acestor operații împreună este dată de acest produs
pe care îl vezi chiar aici,
și observi că ordinea
este din nou inversată exact din același motiv ca înainte.
Deci pe scurt, compozițiile
de operații probabilistice sunt reprezentate de produse
ale matricelor stocastice care le reprezintă.
Ținând minte că aceasta este
ordinea matricelor în produs.
Vei obține întotdeauna o matrice stocastică luând un produs de
matrice stocastice ca aceasta, și uneori exprimăm acest fapt
spunând că
matricele stocastice sunt închise sub înmulțire, și modul în care
poți gândi la aceasta este că nu poți ieși din
setul de matrice stocastice
înmulțindu-le, deoarece setul este închis.
Revenind la
ordinea matricelor în acest produs, este important să observăm că ordinea chiar contează.
Înmulțirea matricelor nu este comutativă. Dacă schimbi ordinea
matricelor în produs, s-ar putea schimba rezultatul,
și nu trebuie să căutăm mai departe decât operațiile deterministe pentru a vedea asta.
Iată un exemplu simplu de
două matrice stocastice, ambele reprezentând
operații deterministe unde ordinea contează.
M1 reprezintă funcția constantă zero. Presupunând că ne imaginăm că aceste două operații sunt pe biți, la fel ca în exemplul de mai devreme.
M2 reprezintă operația not
sau un bit flip.
Dacă efectuezi M1 primul
și apoi efectuezi M2, rezultatul este această matrice chiar aici, care reprezintă
funcția constantă unu.
Dacă setezi un bit la zero
și apoi îl inversezi, este același lucru cu a seta
acel bit la unu.
Pe de altă parte, dacă efectuezi M2 primul
și apoi efectuezi M1, acesta este rezultatul chiar aici,
și aceasta are sens, deoarece dacă inversezi un bit
și apoi îl setezi la zero, este același lucru cu a
îl seta pur și simplu la zero.
Nu a contat că l-ai inversat. Evident, aceste două
matrice nu sunt identice, și deci avem un exemplu foarte
simplu care revelează
că ordinea contează. Desigur, aceasta nu este surprinzătoare deloc.
Știm cu toții că ordinea în care
operațiile sunt efectuate contează sau cel puțin, poate conta.
De exemplu, dacă aprinzi un
chibrit și apoi sufli pe el, rezultatul este foarte diferit
față de a sufla pe chibrit mai întâi
și apoi a-l aprinde. La acest punct, am vorbit destul de mult
despre informația clasică și acum a venit în sfârșit momentul să
discutăm informația cuantică.
Și ceea ce vom descoperi este că
matematic vorbind, informația cuantică funcționează
într-un mod foarte similar cu informația clasică
cu câteva diferențe cheie.
Prima diferență cheie
este chiar la început, cum definim o stare, în acest caz, o stare cuantică a unui sistem,
și există un sens în care această alegere, cum
definim o stare cuantică, determină în mare parte cum
funcționează informația cuantică.
Vom defini de asemenea cum
funcționează măsurările și operațiile, iar în lecția următoare, vom discuta cum
funcționează informația cuantică nu doar pentru sisteme individuale
ci și pentru sisteme multiple,
dar aceste lucruri urmează de fapt
destul de natural odată ce noțiunea de stare cuantică a unui sistem individual în
izolare a fost stabilită.
Iată definiția. O stare cuantică a unui sistem este reprezentată de un vector coloană ale cărui indici sunt puși
în corespondență cu
stările clasice ale acelui sistem.
Deci presupunem aici că
sistemul despre care vorbim are un set de stări clasice, la fel ca atunci când am vorbit
despre informația clasică
și stările probabilistice. Intrările dintr-un vector de stare cuantică sunt numere complexe, spre deosebire de cazul probabilistic
unde intrările sunt
numere reale non-negative.
Și de data aceasta, suma pătratelor valorilor absolute
ale intrărilor trebuie să fie egală cu unu, spre deosebire de sumă egală cu unu
cum avem în cazul probabilistic.
Numerele complexe care apar
într-un vector de stare cuantică se numesc uneori amplitudini și au un rol
similar cu probabilitățile,
dar nu sunt probabilități și nu au
aceeași interpretare.
Acum, nu îți pot da un motiv bun pentru care stările cuantice
ar trebui definite astfel, altul decât a spune că
fizicienii au descoperit
că această definiție
este fizic relevantă și ne permite să descriem și modelăm
sistemele mecanice cuantice.
Cu alte cuvinte, alegem această definiție
pentru că funcționează, nu pentru că există
motive particulare pentru care stările cuantice ar trebui
definite astfel.
În ceea ce privește
matematica acestei noțiuni de stare cuantică, primul pas spre înțelegerea și lucrul cu ea este
să ne amintim această definiție
pentru norma euclidiană a unui vector, pe care o poți gândi geometric ca lungimea unui vector, la fel cum ai gândi despre lungimea
unui vector real bidimensional dacă l-ai desena pe o bucată
de hârtie ca o săgeată pornind din origine în mod obișnuit.
WEBVTT
Mai specific, dacă avem un
vector coloană v ca acesta, despre care presupunem că are
intrări cu numere complexe, alpha unu până la alpha n,
atunci norma euclidiană a lui v este definită după cum se vede chiar aici.
Aceasta este notația pe care
o folosim pentru norma euclidiană, punând aceste bare duble în jurul oricărui vector despre care vorbim.
În acest caz, este v, și modul în care norma euclidiană este definită este că este rădăcina pătrată a sumei
pătratelor valorilor absolute
ale intrărilor vectorului.
Deci un alt mod de a defini ce
este un vector de stare cuantică este că un vector de stare cuantică este un vector coloană cu
intrări cu numere complexe
a cărei normă euclidiană este egală cu unu, ceea ce înseamnă că este un vector unitar față de norma euclidiană.
Aceasta deoarece suma
pătratelor valorii absolute este egală cu unu dacă și numai dacă norma euclidiană
este egală cu unu.
Rădăcina pătrată nu schimbă nimic când suma pătratelor valorilor
absolute este egală cu unu.
Deci acesta este un vector de stare cuantică. Este un vector coloană cu indici care corespund stărilor
clasice ale unui sistem
cu intrări cu numere complexe și normă euclidiană egală cu unu.
Ce înseamnă asta sau ce implică sau cum ar trebui să interpretăm această
noțiune este o altă chestiune și, în anumite privințe,
studiul informației și computației cuantice este o explorare a ceea ce
implică această definiție, cel puțin, în termeni de
procesare a informației.
Acesta este pur și simplu punctul de plecare.
Ca o paranteză, să menționez că există
și alte norme pe lângă norma euclidiană și această notație de
aici cu barele duble
în jurul unui vector nu înseamnă întotdeauna
norma euclidiană.
În contexte diferite, această notație ar putea face referire
la o normă diferită.
De exemplu, suma
valorilor absolute fără pătrate sau rădăcini pătrate este o normă diferită,
adesea numită norma unu. Există de fapt destul de multe
norme diferite.
Uneori vei vedea
această notație folosită cu un indice după
al doilea set de bare, care oferă mai multe informații despre norma despre care vorbim.
Și când facem asta, este destul de tipic că numărul doi ca indice
înseamnă norma euclidiană.
Dar în această serie, ori de câte ori avem un
vector coloană ca acesta, această notație cu bare duble în sine
înseamnă norma euclidiană.
Iată câteva exemple
de vectori de stare cuantică și acești vectori particulari de stare cuantică sunt vectori de stare qubit,
ceea ce înseamnă că
stările clasice ale sistemului nostru sunt zero și unu.
Cuvântul qubit vine de la quantum bit, care este practic doar un bit
care poate fi într-o stare cuantică.
Primele două exemple sunt cu adevărat simple. Vectorii de bază standard
ket zero și ket unu sunt vectori de stare cuantică.
Ambii sunt vectori coloană, iar indicii corespund
stărilor clasice zero și unu, iar intrările acestor
vectori sunt numere complexe.
Pentru acești vectori particulari, intrările sunt zero și unu, care sunt numere reale, și de fapt sunt numere întregi, dar sunt și numere complexe
care se întâmplă să aibă
partea imaginară egală cu zero.
Fiecare vector are o intrare egală cu unu și una egală cu zero.
Deci când sumăm pătratele valorilor absolute
ale intrărilor, obținem unu în ambele cazuri.
Deci condițiile
necesare pentru ca acești vectori să fie vectori de stare cuantică sunt îndeplinite.
Următoarele două exemple sunt stări qubit foarte des întâlnite numite starea plus și starea minus.
Sunt notate după cum
se vede pe ecran, fie cu ket plus
fie cu ket minus ca acesta, și sunt definite
după cum se poate vedea chiar aici.
Din nou, intrările acestor
vectori sunt numere complexe. De data aceasta, sunt fie pozitiv unu peste rădăcina pătrată din doi, fie negativ unu peste rădăcina pătrată din doi,
și când sumăm
pătratele valorilor absolute, obținem 1/2 plus 1/2, care este unu.
Apropo, punând un
semn plus sau minus în interiorul unui ket ca acesta
ar putea părea puțin ciudat, deoarece acestea nu sunt stări clasice
ale sistemului nostru,
dar această notație este folosită totuși, și vom reveni la aceasta imediat.
Dar pentru moment, pe scurt, putem folosi notația Dirac pentru a pune orice nume dorim pentru un vector în interiorul unui ket.
Vectorul nu trebuie să fie
un vector de bază standard când folosim notația Dirac.
Iată un exemplu final de stare qubit
pentru moment, oricum.
Este un vector de stare cuantică al unui qubit care nu are un nume special și nu este deosebit de semnificativ.
Intrările acestui vector sunt unu plus doi ori i
peste trei și minus 2/3.
Acestea sunt numere complexe, și dacă calculezi
pătratele valorilor absolute ale acestor două intrări, vei obține 5/9 pentru prima
și 4/9 pentru a doua. Deci suma pătratelor valorii
absolute este egală cu unu.
Și iată un ultim exemplu. De data aceasta pentru un sistem
ale cărui stări clasice sunt cele patru culori ale cărților de joc.
Nu știu de ce am avea un sistem ale cărui stări clasice
sunt cele patru culori ale cărților și care se află într-o stare cuantică, dar este posibil în principiu
și este doar un exemplu.
WEBVTT
Intrările corespunzătoare
diferitelor culori sunt 1/2 pentru treflă, minus
i peste doi pentru caro,
zero pentru inimă deoarece nu apare în sumă și unu peste rădăcina
pătrată din doi pentru pică.
Și iată cum arată
ca vector coloană, presupunând că am ordonat
stările clasice cum am făcut înainte,
care este ordinea
pe care o vezi chiar aici.
Luând pătratul valorii absolute
al acestor intrări dă un sfert pentru prima, de asemenea un sfert pentru următoarea.
Pătratul valorii absolute
al lui zero este egal cu zero, deci acea intrare nu
contribuie la sumă.
Și în final, pentru ultima, obținem 1/2. Deci suma este egală cu unu, cum se cere pentru ca acest vector
să fie un vector de stare cuantică.
Acum, chiar cu un moment în urmă, am folosit notația
ket plus și ket minus pentru a ne referi la doi vectori de stare qubit care nu sunt vectori de bază standard.
Și aș vrea să revin
la acest punct pe scurt și să explic cum se folosește notația Dirac pentru vectori arbitrari și nu doar pentru vectorii de bază standard.
După cum am menționat deja, putem folosi orice nume dorim
în interiorul unui bra sau ket pentru a ne referi la un vector.
Ket-urile sunt vectori coloană
și bra-urile sunt vectori rând, la fel ca înainte.
De exemplu, litera greacă
psi este foarte des folosită în interiorul unui ket pentru a se referi la un vector arbitrar,
și aici, o folosim pentru
a da un nume vectorului de stare de mai devreme care
nu are un nume special.
Când facem asta, litera psi nu
are neapărat vreo semnificație prin ea însăși.
Este doar numele unui vector, și este în interiorul unui ket pentru a ne ajuta să clarificăm
că este un vector coloană.
Aceasta poate fi puțin
confuză uneori, și există un potențial pentru ambiguitate dacă litera psi ar putea fi asociată
cu o stare clasică a
unui sistem, de exemplu, dar în general nu
cauzează probleme, și nu trebuie să folosești notația Dirac astfel
dacă nu dorești. Folosirea unei litere mici cum ar fi
u, v sau w fără un ket este de asemenea o modalitate bună de
a denota un vector coloană
sau mai specific,
un vector de stare cuantică.
Este alegerea ta ce notație
folosești pentru a te exprima.
Trebuie doar să te asiguri
că în primul rând, semnificația a ceea ce
încerci să exprimi este clară pentru alții.
Și în al doilea rând, că înțelegi ceea ce
alții încearcă să exprime, chiar și atunci când preferințele lor de notație nu sunt la fel ca ale tale.
Există o regulă foarte importantă pentru folosirea notației Dirac
pentru vectori arbitrari și aceea este că dacă ai un vector coloană
pe care ai decis să îl scrii
ca ket psi, de exemplu, sau ar putea fi un
alt nume în interiorul unui ket, atunci vectorul rând bra psi
este înțeles să fie
conjugatul transpus al vectorului ket psi.
Și iată, aceasta este scrisă ca o ecuație unde acest dagger chiar aici se referă la conjugatul transpus.
Ce înseamnă mai specific asta este
vectorul rând pe care îl obții prin, în primul rând, transpunerea vectorului, ceea ce înseamnă că îl întorci pe o parte și îl schimbi dintr-o coloană în rând
fără a schimba de fapt intrările. Și în al doilea rând, luând conjugatul complex
al fiecărei intrări.
Poți de fapt efectua
acele două operații, transpunerea și
conjugatul complex intrare cu intrare, în orice ordine, deoarece
cele două operații comutează.
Deci pentru vectorul din acest exemplu, dat că am decis să
numim acest vector ket psi, se înțelege că bra psi
înseamnă acest vector chiar aici
unde am transpus vectorul transformând ket zero și ket
unu în bra zero și bra unu, și am luat conjugatul complex al fiecărei intrări,
motiv pentru care unu plus
doi ori i peste trei se transformă în unu minus doi
ori i peste trei chiar aici.
Iată cum arată acești vectori când sunt scrieți
explicit ca vector coloană și vector rând.
Observă, apropo, că
această regulă este consistentă cu notația pe care o folosim când avem stări clasice
în interiorul bra-ului și ket-ului.
În acel caz, intrările sunt
toate zero cu excepția unui unu, și deci luarea conjugatelor complexe nu face nimic în acel caz.
Am văzut acum cum stările cuantice sunt reprezentate ca vectori, dar nu este clar la acest
punct care este semnificația sau implicațiile
în termeni de ceea ce
poți face cu sistemul într-o stare cuantică sau cum poți interacționa cu el.
Primul lucru pe care trebuie să îl facem pentru a aduce aceste probleme în focus
este să discutăm măsurările.
Intuitiv vorbind,
măsurările oferă un mecanism pentru extragerea informației clasice
din sistemele cuantice.
Când ne uităm la un sistem
când se află într-o stare cuantică, nu vedem o stare cuantică, la fel cum nu vedem
stări probabilistice,
vedem stări clasice, iar această noțiune de măsurare este cea care oferă interfața.
Dacă noi, ca oameni, vrem să știm ceva despre un sistem cuantic, trebuie să îl măsurăm, și procedând astfel vom extrage informații clasice
despre orice stare cuantică
în care se afla acel sistem.
Există diferite
noțiuni de măsurări. Diferența este una
de generalitate de fapt, și vom începe cu cea mai simplă și de bază,
care se numește de obicei o
măsurare în baza standard.
WEBVTT
Vom generaliza aceasta
în lecțiile ulterioare. Vom vorbi despre așa-numitele
măsurări proiective în lecția trei, și apoi mai târziu în
unitatea a treia a seriei,
vom vorbi despre măsurările generale, care se mai numesc și măsuri cu valori de operator pozitive
sau POVM pe scurt.
Dar pentru moment, ne vom restricționa atenția la măsurările în baza standard.
Când o măsurare este
efectuată pe un sistem, va exista un set
de posibile rezultate ale acelei măsurări, care sunt rezultate clasice,
și în cazul unei
măsurări în baza standard, acele posibile rezultate sunt
exact stările clasice ale oricărui sistem care este măsurat.
Fiecare dintre acele stări clasice va fi rezultatul măsurării cu o anumită probabilitate, iar probabilitatea respectivă este pătratul valorii absolute
al intrării corespunzătoare
acelei stări clasice, din orice vector de stare cuantică în care se afla sistemul imediat înainte de a fi măsurat.
Știm că pătratul valorii absolute al oricărui număr complex este un număr real non-negativ, și știm din definiția
vectorilor de stare cuantică
că suma pătratelor valorii
absolute ale intrărilor unui vector de stare cuantică este egală cu unu.
Deci aceasta are sens. Fiecare stare clasică va apărea ca rezultat al
măsurării cu o anumită probabilitate, iar probabilitățile sumează la unu.
Iată câteva exemple. Mai întâi, să presupunem că avem un
qubit în starea plus.
Dacă măsurăm acest qubit cu o
măsurare în baza standard, obținem fie zero fie
unu ca rezultat.
Probabilitatea de a obține zero este pătratul valorii absolute
al lui unu peste rădăcina din doi, care este 1/2, iar aceea este aceeași
probabilitate de a obține unu.
Deci dacă măsori o stare plus, vei obține un bit aleatoriu uniform.
Dacă sistemul se află în starea minus
în loc de starea plus, atunci măsurarea funcționează în
exact același mod.
Probabilitățile sunt, din nou, 1/2 pentru fiecare posibil rezultat.
Singura diferență de aici este că semnul plus s-a transformat în minus, dar când luăm valoarea
absolută, nimic nu se schimbă.
Dacă măsurăm această stare qubit, probabilitatea de a obține rezultatul zero este pătratul valorii absolute al lui unu plus doi ori i
peste trei, care este 5/9,
și probabilitatea de a obține rezultatul unu este pătratul valorii absolute
al lui negativ 2/3, care este 4/9.
Și în final, măsurând
starea bazei standard, ket zero dă rezultatul
zero cu certitudine, și similar, măsurând starea ket unu
produce rezultatul unu cu certitudine. Aceasta deoarece pătratul valorii absolute
al lui unu este unu.
Similar cu ceea ce am avut în
cadrul probabilistic. Putem asocia aceste stări cuantice, ket zero în ket unu, cu sistemul aflat în
acele stări clasice,
și acest exemplu este consistent
cu acea interpretare.
Acum, la fel cum am avut în
cadrul probabilistic, dacă măsurăm un sistem când
se află într-o stare cuantică,
atunci starea se va schimba, în general, ca urmare a
efectuării acelei măsurări.
În particular, și din nou, aceasta este exact cum am avut
în cadrul probabilistic.
Dacă măsurăm un sistem și rezultatul măsurării
este starea clasică a, atunci noua stare cuantică
a sistemului devine ket a.
Deci pentru această stare
chiar de mai sus, de exemplu, vedem același tip
de comportament pe care l-am avut în cadrul probabilistic.
Dacă măsurăm, atunci cu probabilitatea 5/9, obținem rezultatul zero, caz în care starea
trece la ket zero,
și cu probabilitatea
4/9, rezultatul este unu, iar starea trece la ket unu.
Uneori acest fenomen este numit colapsul
stării cuantice, și este genul de lucru care îi ține treji pe oamenii
care studiază fundamentele
mecanicii cuantice.
Dar dintr-o perspectivă pur
matematică, este cu adevărat destul de simplu
și foarte asemănător cu ceea ce avem în cazul probabilistic.
Sursa tensiunii de aici, în anumite privințe, se referă la natura fundamentală a stărilor cuantice și la ce reprezintă ele
și cum diferă
de stările probabilistice. Dar la nivel matematic, aceasta este poate ceea ce te-ai putea aștepta.
Observă, apropo, că dacă
ai măsura a doua oară, atunci ai obține exact
același rezultat ca la prima măsurare.
Deci există o limită privind câtă
informație clasică poate fi extrasă dintr-o stare cuantică, și vom reveni la acest punct curând
într-o altă lecție. Am vorbit despre stările cuantice, cât și despre măsurări, mai specific măsurări în baza standard,
care oferă o modalitate de
a extrage informații clasice din stările cuantice.
Subiectul rămas pentru
această lecție este operațiile, mai specific operațiile unitare, care descriu cum
stările cuantice ale sistemelor
pot fi schimbate. Natural, dat că
vectorii de stare cuantică sunt diferiți față de vectorii de probabilitate, te-ai putea aștepta ca setul
de operații permise
pe stările cuantice să fie diferit față de ceea ce avem pentru
informația clasică, și într-adevăr, acesta este cazul.
În timp ce operațiile pe stările probabilistice sunt reprezentate de matrice stocastice, operațiile pe vectorii de stare cuantică
sunt reprezentate de matrice unitare.
Iată definiția matricelor unitare.
O matrice pătrată U cu
intrări cu numere complexe este unitară dacă satisface egalitățile
pe care le vezi chiar aici.
WEBVTT
Dagger-ul reprezintă
conjugatul transpus, pe care l-am văzut deja pentru vectori când am vorbit despre notația Dirac
acum câteva momente.
Aici efectuăm
conjugatul transpus pe o matrice în loc de un vector, dar este în esență același lucru.
Transpunem matricea, ceea ce înseamnă că
schimbăm rândurile și coloanele, deci intrarea JK devine intrarea KJ,
și luăm de asemenea conjugatul complex
al fiecărei intrări.
De asemenea, această notație chiar de mai sus
înseamnă matricea identitate.
Aceste două egalități de chiar
de mai sus sunt de fapt echivalente. Dacă ai una, atunci
o ai automat și pe cealaltă.
Ambele sunt echivalente cu
a spune că U este inversabilă, iar inversa este egală
la conjugatul transpus.
Aceasta este valabilă doar pentru matrice
pătrate, apropo. Dacă ai o matrice care nu este pătrată, atunci una dintre cele două
egalități ar putea fi adevărată,
dar cealaltă nu va fi adevărată.
Dar aici, vorbim
despre matrice pătrate.
Deci aceasta este definiția standard
pentru matricele unitare, și este convenabilă deoarece este ușor să verificăm
dacă o matrice este unitară.
Înmulțești pur și simplu matricea cu conjugatul ei transpus pe oricare parte, și verifici dacă obții
matricea identitate.
Există un mod echivalent de a caracteriza matricele unitare, și anume că o
matrice pătrată este unitară dacă și numai dacă nu schimbă niciodată norma euclidiană
a niciunui vector când îl înmulțești. O matrice N pe N U este unitară dacă și numai dacă
norma euclidiană a lui U ori v
este egală cu norma euclidiană a lui v, pentru orice vector coloană n-dimensional v cu intrări cu numere complexe.
Și deci, dacă v este
un vector de stare cuantică, atunci U ori v este de asemenea
un vector de stare cuantică, deoarece vectorii de stare cuantică
sunt pur și simplu vectorii cu
normă euclidiană egală cu unu.
De fapt, putem spune puțin mai mult, și anume că matricele unitare sunt exact matricele care transformează întotdeauna vectorii de stare cuantică
în vectori de stare cuantică. Aceasta este o situație similară cu ceea ce avem pentru matricele stocastice
și vectorii de probabilitate.
Matricele stocastice
sunt exact matricele care transformează întotdeauna vectorii de probabilitate în vectori de probabilitate.
Deci odată ce am decis că operațiile ar trebui reprezentate de matrice, ceea ce este același lucru cu a spune că transformările acționează liniar
pe vectorii reprezentând stările, aceste alegeri pentru seturile
de operații permise urmează în mod natural, cel puțin,
în sens matematic.
Acum să aruncăm o privire la câteva exemple de operații unitare qubit.
Vom vedea mult mai multe exemple
de operații unitare în lecțiile ulterioare, inclusiv operații unitare pe sisteme
cu mai mult de două stări clasice. Dar pentru moment, ne vom concentra doar
pe operațiile unitare qubit.
Vom vedea aceste
exemple particulare revenind din nou și din nou, deci merită cu siguranță să cunoști
aceste operații.
Prima colecție de exemple sunt așa-numitele operații Pauli.
Acestea sunt operațiile care corespund matricelor Pauli, care sunt prezentate aici.
Toate sunt unitare, și poți verifica asta pentru fiecare una conform definiției de mai devreme.
Aceste matrice particulare
se întâmplă să fie egale cu propriile lor conjugate transpuse, ceea ce înseamnă că sunt
toate matrice Hermitiene.
Deci verificarea că sunt
toate unitare, în acest caz, este o chestiune de a ridica la pătrat fiecare una și de a vedea că rezultatul
este matricea identitate.
Numele pe care le vezi pentru aceste
matrice sunt destul de standard, și vei vedea de asemenea sigma
x, sigma y și sigma z numite pur și simplu X, Y și Z.
Fii conștient, totuși, că
literele mari X, Y și Z sunt de asemenea des folosite în alte scopuri, chiar și în contextul
informației cuantice,
dar ele sunt nume foarte comune
pentru aceste matrice.
Operația sigma x sau X
se mai numește și bit flip sau operație not, pe care am văzut-o deja
în contextul clasic.
Iar operația sigma z sau Z
se mai numește și phase flip.
Și iată, poți vedea
acțiunea acestor operații pe vectorii de bază standard, ceea ce explică oarecum
de unde vin aceste nume.
Cu siguranță, are sens să
ne referim la sigma x ca bit flip pe baza acestei acțiuni chiar de mai sus.
Pur și simplu inversează bitul de la
zero la unu sau de la unu la zero.
De asemenea, are sens să
numim sigma z un phase flip pe baza acestei acțiuni chiar de mai sus.
Dar dacă nu este complet clar
în acest moment, este în regulă.
Vom întâlni această
operație din nou și din nou, iar semnificația
de a pune un semn minus în fața vectorului de bază ket unu și nu ket zero
și de ce se numește phase flip va fi mai clar mai târziu.
Următorul exemplu este
operația Hadamard, care este reprezentată de
această matrice chiar de mai sus, care este aproape întotdeauna numită H.
Verificarea că H este unitară este din nou
un calcul simplu, pe care dacă dau la o parte, îl poți vedea chiar de mai sus.
Similar cu matricele Pauli, H este propriul ei conjugat transpus.
Deci avem această egalitate chiar de mai sus, și când efectuăm înmulțirea, obținem matricea identitate, cum se cere.
WEBVTT
Al treilea exemplu este
de fapt o întreagă clasă de operații unitare
cunoscute sub numele de operații de fază.
Acestea sunt operații
reprezentate de orice matrice care are această formă
pe care o vezi chiar de mai sus, unde theta este orice număr real.
Deci această intrare de chiar de mai sus va fi
întotdeauna un număr complex pe cercul unitate.
Matricele ca aceasta sunt întotdeauna unitare, ceea ce voi lăsa pentru tine să verifici.
De data aceasta, conjugatul transpus nu va fi egal cu matricea originală, cu excepția cazului în care acest număr de mai sus
se întâmplă să fie unu sau minus unu,
caz în care ajungem fie
cu matricea identitate, fie cu sigma z, pe care le-am
întâlnit deja.
Mai specific, transpunerea
nu va face nimic acestei matrice, dar luând conjugatul complex al fiecărei intrări, schimbă această intrare chiar de mai sus
la e la minus i theta.
Aceste două operații particulare de mai sus sunt exemple deosebit de importante de operații de fază.
Pentru prima, luăm
theta egal cu pi peste doi, și obținem această matrice chiar de mai sus.
Aceasta se numește de obicei o
operație S sau un gate S când vorbim despre circuit-uri, despre care nu vom discuta în această lecție,
dar acesta este un subiect important
care vine în curând.
A doua este această operație. Este o operație T sau un gate T.
Și pentru aceasta, theta
este egal cu pi peste patru. Și deci când calculăm exponențiala, obținem această valoare chiar de mai sus, care este unu plus i peste
rădăcina pătrată din doi.
Iată câteva exemple rapide pentru a vedea câteva dintre aceste
operații în acțiune.
Iată acțiunea
operației Hadamard pe ket zero și ket unu.
Dacă parcurgem
înmulțirea matrice-vector, vedem că ceea ce obținem sunt starea plus și starea
minus respectiv.
Dacă efectuăm operația Hadamard pe starea plus și starea
minus, pe de altă parte, ne întoarcem la ket zero și ket unu.
Deci dacă curățăm un pic lucrurile, putem vedea acțiunea mai clar.
Operația Hadamard
transformă înapoi și înainte între starea zero și starea plus și între starea unu
și starea minus.
Referitor la aceste două ecuații chiar de mai sus, observă că aceasta ne oferă o modalitate simplă de a detecta diferența între o stare plus și o stare minus.
Cum am văzut mai devreme în lecție, dacă măsurăm o stare plus
și o stare minus cu o
măsurare în baza standard,
obținem un bit aleatoriu uniform în ambele cazuri, ceea ce nu ne ajută să
detectăm diferența.
Dar dacă efectuăm o operație Hadamard și apoi măsurăm, vom vedea zero dacă
starea originală era starea plus
și unu dacă starea originală
era starea minus.
Deci aceste două stări sunt într-adevăr diferite și pot fi discriminate
perfect prin metoda pe care tocmai am descris-o,
și anume să efectuezi mai întâi
o operație Hadamard și apoi să măsori.
Revenind la exemplul unei
stări qubit pe care l-am văzut înainte și care nu este deosebit de specială, putem vedea ce face operația Hadamard
stării
convertind la formele
pe care le vezi chiar de mai sus și efectuând înmulțirea.
Și iată rezultatul
pe care îl putem converti înapoi la notația Dirac dacă dorim,
și aceasta este o modalitate de a calcula
aceste tipuri de acțiuni.
Iată un alt exemplu care ilustrează că nu trebuie întotdeauna
să convertești explicit la o formă matrice-vector.
Poți efectua de asemenea aceste
calcule direct folosind notația Dirac.
Acest exemplu privește operația T, și iată-l chiar de mai sus
doar pentru referință.
Această operație are această acțiune chiar de mai sus pe stările bazei standard.
Și dacă vrem să calculăm
acțiunea operației T pe o stare plus, de exemplu, putem începe prin a extinde
definiția stării plus
și apoi folosi liniaritatea
pentru a exprima rezultatul după cum se vede chiar de mai sus.
Putem acum pur și simplu să inserăm
aceste expresii de mai sus, să facem puțină
simplificare pentru al doilea termen și obținem rezultatul.
Dacă din orice motiv am vrea să aplicăm o operație Hadamard
rezultatului, putem face ceva similar.
Mai întâi, substituim expresia pentru T acționând pe starea plus și folosim liniaritatea ca am făcut înainte.
Și acum, dacă substituim
expresiile pe care le avem deja pentru operația Hadamard
acționând pe ket zero și ket unu,
obținem asta. Și acum, putem extinde starea plus și starea minus pentru a obține această expresie chiar de mai sus,
pe care o putem simplifica pur și simplu adunând, și iată rezultatul final.
Nu există nimic deosebit de special
despre acest exemplu. Este menit pur și simplu să
ilustreze această modalitate alternativă dar echivalentă de
a calcula acțiunile
ale acestor operații. Poți folosi oricare
modalitate este mai convenabilă în situația dată.
Un punct final despre
operațiile unitare este că compozițiile de operații unitare
sunt reprezentate de înmulțirea matricelor
la fel ca în cadrul probabilistic, adică poți calcula acțiunea unei secvențe de operații unitare
înmulțind pur și simplu
matricele împreună. Și ceea ce vei obține este
o singură matrice unitară reprezentând acțiunea combinată
WEBVTT
a secvenței de operații.
La fel cum am avut pentru matricele stocastice, matricele unitare sunt
închise sub înmulțire, deci vei obține întotdeauna o matrice unitară
când compui operații unitare.
Trebuie să te asiguri
că înmulțești matricele în ordinea corectă.
Dar modul în care funcționează este la fel ca pentru
operațiile stocastice, unde matricea pentru prima operație pe care o efectuezi
va apărea întotdeauna pe partea dreaptă
a produsului de matrice, iar ultima va apărea
pe partea stângă.
Deci la fel ca înainte, ordinea este inversată în sensul că compui de la dreapta la stânga în loc de la stânga la dreapta.
Iată un exemplu interesant care dă naștere unei operații cunoscute sub numele de operația rădăcina pătrată din not.
Să presupunem că mai întâi
aplicăm o operație Hadamard urmată de o operație S, urmată de o altă operație Hadamard.
Acțiunea combinată a
acestor trei operații este descrisă de acest produs.
Iată prima operație Hadamard, iată operația S și iată a doua operație Hadamard.
Dacă efectuăm înmulțirea matricelor, care nu este prezentată aici explicit, dar o poți face singur dacă vrei,
rezultatul este această matrice chiar de mai sus. Este o matrice unitară, și o putem verifica fie direct
sau ne putem încrede în faptul că matricele unitare sunt
închise sub înmulțire.
Trebuie să fie unitară deoarece aceste trei matrice sunt unitare, după cum am văzut deja.
Nu avem în minte niciun
vector particular de stare cuantică.
Ne putem imagina efectuând
această secvență de operații pe orice vector de stare cuantică, iar această matrice descrie acțiunea.
Motivul pentru care această operație combinată, adică cea descrisă
de această matrice chiar de mai sus, se numește operația rădăcina din not,
este că efectuând-o
de două ori, obținem o operație not, sau cu alte cuvinte, o
operație sigma x sau X.
Efectuând operația
de două ori este reprezentat prin ridicarea la pătrat a matricei sau
înmulțind-o cu ea însăși.
Și dacă faci asta, vei vedea că rezultatul
este matricea Pauli x.
Și aceasta este destul de ciudat și îți oferă un indiciu că poți face unele lucruri interesante cu informația cuantică pe care nu le poți face cu
informația clasică.
Nu există nicio operație clasică, adică una reprezentată
de o matrice stocastică, care să ne dea o operație not
dacă o efectuăm de două ori.
Deci este un exemplu frumos care revelează că operațiile cuantice
se comportă foarte diferit față de operațiile clasice.
Și gata cu lecția unu. În această lecție, am discutat cum funcționează informația cuantică pentru sisteme individuale în izolare,
și în lecția următoare, vom vorbi despre cum
funcționează informația cuantică pentru sisteme multiple.
Mulțumesc că ai urmărit. Dacă ai întrebări, nu ezita să le lași
în secțiunea de comentarii de mai jos.